all right we're here cooking out of her
beautiful cookware also I'm throwing in
just a tiny bit more butter
and then what you're going to do is
you're going to take your pasta straight
from the water and just transfer it
because you want that pasta water and
then you go in with your tongs and your
toss it's that easy you want to make
sure to Splash the crap out of yourself
and make a huge mess and then you want
to just top it with some fresh
um parsley and that's what makes it look
like all restaurant style
garnish changes everything yeah there we
go I mean when they called you and said
you know did you go to them did they
come to you because searching for Italy
really made a huge impact on television
on our culture the way I view CNN yeah
and you've been such a foodie since you
came onto the scene and like burst on
and we're like hi I'm Eva Longoria I'm
here you are also synonymous with your
love of food your restaurants your
cookbooks your culinary world so this
just seems like such a perfect authentic
fit it was well they did come to me
Stanley came to me and he told me they
were going to do a spin-off and I was
such a fan of searching for Italy and I
thought he did it so beautifully and
then uh but I pitched them Mexico I was
like I would love to do Mexico because
it is
um just so beautiful and rich in its
culture and I think what you said like
the easiest entry point for any culture
is food so food is a really yep yeah
don't get it in your uh and it's just an
easy way into any culture and I think
that oh my God I'm so excited
yeah
um hold on will you play kitchen
confessions with me yes but I want to
taste this I'm like watering at the
mouth I know can you guys smell this I
wish people at home could smell it yeah
I need that butter yeah you need that
Jew
um all right time to confess here we go
as we slurp slurping and confessing
um have you ever gone skinny dipping and
if so where oh my God I think I grew yes
I grew up skinny dipping like I grew up
on a ranch so oh we were always naked
we're always naked and we didn't go like
in a lake we went where the cows drink
the water like that was our that was our
pool
what about as an adult
probably yeah yeah yeah hotels
no no you guys don't do that never mind
no I just thinking like we should go
take a vacation
you need to travel but yeah every chance
I get yeah I don't like clothes
absolutely I don't like I sleep naked
sometimes yeah you have the ability
to hear every single thing that anyone
has ever said about you good or bad but
once you start you can't stop would you
want to hear it or say pass pass in my
head I think people like me oh that's so
good yeah oh that's so healthy do you
like you in your head I do I love me
so if there's one thing that you knew
um that you could do and there would be
no consequences what would you do
eating yes
we didn't have to exercise so much I'm
so tired of exercising
I would be eating it would be eating
could you imagine no consequences I want
to be naked on vacation with you yeah
eating
[Applause]
it is all good I cannot thank you enough
for putting the show out into the world
searching for Mexico Premiere Sunday
March 26 at 10 p.m on CNN and I gotta
tell you CNN just got it right with this
show we're all in love with it and on
the feeder so thank you for carrying
that torch and bringing us all back in
so important country of Mexico
[Applause]
I guess if you do have to put clothes on
Katie storino is going to help you Katie
hates us
[Music]